[Music]
discovery now making one last reach for
the stars
well space is the latest frontier in the
war with russia the head of russia space
program dimitri rogozin says sanctions
have destroyed space unity and the
country were pulled out of the
international space station well dynasty
the former nasa astronaut retired u.s
navy captain scott kelly joins me now so
good to have you on the show scott
lovely to talk to you again how are you
i'm good pierce uh thanks for having me
just quickly what impact does this have
if anything russia pulling out of the
space station like this
well it would have a significant impact
to the international space station
program
russia is one of the critical partners
the space station is something i think
that people look up to as an example of
international cooperation
nasa relies on russia russia relies on
nasa to operate and maintain the space
station so if they were to
just suddenly leave it would create some
significant
problems
in continuing to operate
you um have been quite vocal about
what's been going on with this there's a
sort of ongoing debate isn't there about
what we do with russian individuals in
sport and culture and so on i mean is
there an argument for the global
community to simply outlaw russian space
programs russian cosmonauts and so on
you know i think it's important enough
to humanity to have a place that is not
on this planet where we can work
cooperatively together
uh peacefully together uh for the
benefit of all of us and you know
currently that's the international space
station
and you know this cooperation started at
the end of the cold war it's been very
successful uh i hope we can continue to
uh maintain this cooperation for
for those reasons and you know also
because i have a lot of friends in
russia that work for the space station
uh program rus cosmos many of them are
very good people
but you know i think at some point i
don't think we're there yet but i do
think at some point uh you know based on
russia's behavior and what they may or
may not do that we could get to the
point where
you know uh you know terrestrial
politics
does uh you know supersede this
important cooperation in space
geopolitically i mean there are things
that russia could do that i think
we could say you know enough is enough
like you said
on a lighter note nasa is sending
drawings of naked humans into space in
the hope of luring aliens towards us
what do you think of that no
well i heard about that today so i
googled it and what it looks like to me
is just something very similar to like
that golden plaque kind of thing that
was put on the voyager spacecraft you
know things that we've left maybe on the
moon on you know the the bottom of the
uh lunar lander you know we came in
peace for all mankind to show like
certain things that demonstrate uh you
know what humans are you know what their
appearance is
it didn't seem to me like it was sending
like you know naughty images into spaces
you would say in britain
i have got a picture actually of myself
in a very substantive uh burger
commercial
uh a few years ago which i think could
be just what we need to attract aliens
to this planet uh or it might of course
have the
it might of course have the complete
opposite effect i'm not sure if you can
see the horrifying picture that's on the
screen right now scott but it's it would
be enough to put any alien off
yeah i i can't see it but if i could
imagine it would probably repel any
alien invaders scott before i let you go
do you have a great unfulfilled dream i
mean your
extraordinary career you've had
including of course going to space do
you have a dream left
well you know as far as like space
flight's concerned i was just happy to
you know have that privilege of flying
in space you know unfortunately like
right now my major focus has been like
speaking out against this war in ukraine
i have ukrainian-american family members
i have uh ukrainian friends i have
russian friends you know certainly the
ukrainians are suffering most of anyone
by far
but uh you know there's a lot of people
i care about so you know my current
dream is for this nightmare of a you
know illegal invasion
uh murders rapes
um you know genocide to be over i mean
that's as far ahead as i'm thinking uh
for me for myself personally right now
scott it's great to talk to you thank
you very much indeed for joining me
thank you pierce